[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 10 octobre journée
d'action dans la fonction publique
manifestation à paris cet après midi
contre plusieurs mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement et notamment la
suppression de 120 mille postes d'ici la
fin du quinquennat présidentiel et bilan
de cette mobilisation avec bertrand
mesure qu'au secrétaire du syndicat
d'enseignants snuipp-fsu des yvelines
il sera avec nous en plateau le
professeur alain duault est le nouveau
président de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines le conseil
d'administration l'a élu la semaine
dernière lui vs cul qui conduit
actuellement des recherches sur
l'amyotrophie spinale maladie
neuromusculaire
un projet mené par le la chercheuse
valérie robin qui est égalment également
l'invité de ce journal et puis comme
tous les mardis le portrait de la
rédaction consacrer une personnalité
yvelinois ce soir zoom sur marie laure
caron depuis 2011 elle est la
responsable du refuge spa de plaisir
un mouvement de grève qui a concerné
aujourd'hui également à saint quentin en
yvelines les fonctionnaires étaient dans
la rue pour une journée d'action motifs
protester contre les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement
suppression de 120 mille postes de
fonctionnaires d'ici la fin du
quinquennat rétablissement de la journée
de carence gel des salaires bonsoir
bertrand mesure qui est avec nous par
téléphone
elle vous êtes co secrétaire du syndicat
d'enseignants f ace à nu ip pfs eu donc
dans les yvelines
vous étiez dans le cortège à paris
manifester aujourd'hui 26 mille
personnes selon la préfecture de police
45000 selon la cgt alors on ne va pas
faire une bataille des chiffres mais
quel est le bilan finalement en cette
fin de journée est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de cette mobilisation fait de
voir que les collègues pour défendre
l'intérêt général et en sortent
cette journée est positive allez faites
pas hauteur de ce qu'on aurait souhaité
mais en tout cas elle était prête
c'est la première fois depuis 2007 que
neuf syndicats appelaient à la grève
aujourd'hui c'est c'est une force quand
on voit par exemple dans le secteur
privé pour la manifestation contre la
réforme du code du travail les syndicats
n'arrivent pas à s'unir là c'est une
force aujourd'hui que vous ayez fait
front commun
bah écoutez je crois que tu es
caractéristiques en termes la fonction
publique fait que manifestement
gouvernement souhaite attaquer l'intérêt
général et la fonction publique est là
pour défendre et pour participer à cet
intérêt général
vous appelez chapet que les dernières
mesures du gouvernement visait plus à
favoriser certaines catégories de
personnes dont ne font partie ni les
fonctionnaires ni les salariés en
général qui ceux du privé sans attaquer
particulièrement violemment concernant
la vie de la loi travail
mais côté ville est ce qu on a une idée
des personnes mobilisées du moins du
côté de votre syndicat à l'écouté moi
j'estime entre 25 et 30% la mobilisation
sachant que les chiffres qui sont
annoncés par les autorités ne sont pas
fiables dans la mesure où ne sont pas
comptabilisés
les enseignants qui ne sont pas
remplacés ou elle par exemple l'époque
du second degré comment alors les motifs
de la protestation les rappels
suppression de deux cent vingt mille
postes de fonctionnaires à d'ici la fin
du quinquennat rétablissement de la
journée de carence gel des salaires des
salaires dernière question qu'exiger
vous concrètement c'est une marche
arrière du gouvernement vous souhaitez
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que la
fonction publique devienne ce qu'elle a
été pendant les trente glorieuses
c'est à dire l'assurance au l'ensemble
des personnes de tous les citoyens
français d'avoir des services publics de
qualité
merci d'être en mesure d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le co
secrétaire de snuipp-75 line autre
mobilisation aujourd'hui celle des
salariés de 10h elle attrape une
vingtaine de personnes ont bloqué au
petit matin
l accès du site du groupe de transport
et logistique
il a récemment perdu l'un de ses clients
et va délocaliser ses locaux aux
yvelinois à mitry mory en seine et marne
et les employés créent une des
suppressions de postes et une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
le mouvement est prolongée jusqu'à au
moins demain en attente d'une réponse de
la direction est dans l'actualité
également 6000 euros damende dont 5000
avec sursis sentence du tribunal
correctionnel de versailles à l'encontre
de l214 de militants de l'association de
défense animale ont été reconnu coupable
hier de violation de domicile en
décembre 2016 il s'était introduit
clandestinement dans l'abattoir guillard
en deux ou dans pour y poser des caméras
et les images filmées montraient la mise
à mort violente de porc et les deux
prévenus ont été en revanche relaxé pour
tentative d'atteinte à la vie privée
15000 euros d'amendé avaient été requis
au départ par le parquet contre eux un
anniversaire à l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny le bretonneux
l'association pégase a fêté ses 25 ans
jeudi 5 octobre anciens et nouveaux
membres se sont rencontrés pour échanger
sur les activités pédagogiques de la
structure retour avec nicolas dans le
riz 25 ans d'existence pour pégase
l'association de l'estaca spécialisée
dans les activités scientifiques pour
enfants à célébrer son anniversaire
étudiant à l'école d'ingénieurs entre
2001 et 2003 eugène était engagée dans
l'association
à 39 ans il est aujourd'hui manager de
projet les souvenirs que j'essaie déjà
l'émerveillement des enfants
à pouvoir ouvrir un champ du possible
sur des séances sur la vie du quotidien
comprendre le fonctionnement de choses
extrêmement complexe les étudiants
interviennent les jeudis après midi dans
des classes d'écoles primaires
expérience ateliers de construction de
maquettes des animations ludiques pour
éveiller les enfants aux sciences comme
intervient aussi donc à l'hôpital
pédiatrique de bullion dans des classes
d'enfants malades
on a aussi un nouveau projet cette année
donc avec
des lycées techniques donc à la celle
saint cloud et attrapes pour toujours
pareil la pédagogie la proche des
sciences autre projet des activités
menées au sénégal organisé au début des
années 2000 ce voyage humanitaire permet
de fournir du matériel scientifique est
de faire découvrir des expériences aux
écoliers sénégalais des compétences
importantes pour les futurs ingénieurs
aujourd'hui en fait quand on interroge
un
recruteur les industriels qui vont
recruter nos jeunes ingénieurs ils nous
disent clairement
ils attendent autant les connaissances
un savoir faire que un savoir-être et
dans le savoir être il ya ces
compétences de pédagogie mise en place
en début d'année des animations sont
dorénavant menée à l'hôpital pédiatrique
de bullion
autre grand établissement d'enseignement
supérieur du territoire avec l'estac
assez lu vs cul bien sûr l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
deux invités m'ont rejoint en plateau
valérie robin bonsoir ça vous êtes
chercheuse au laboratoire biothérapies
des maladies neuromusculaires de levier
lu vs qu alors vous mener un projet de
recherche sur la mieux trop fille
spinale reste avec nous on va en parler
dans quelques instants avec moi
également sur ce plateau alain buis
bonsoir professeur alain but vous êtes
le nouveau président de l'université à
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
alors vous avez été élu la semaine
dernière par le conseil d'administration
de l'université
vous êtes titulaire d'un doctorat en
informatique professeur à l'ufr des
sciences de l'ue vs q depuis 2008 vous
occupiez depuis plus d'un an la fonction
de vice président en charge du conseil
d'administration comment abordez vous ce
nouveau rôle de président merci de le
recevoir
tout d'abord je voudrais dire qu'il
m'était apparu logique tu me porter
candidat à la présidence
suite à la démission de didier guilbault
pour raisons de santé est dans une
logique de continuité et de stabilité
donc au delà de ma candidature c'est la
candidature de toute une équipe qui
était déjà en place et donc dans ce pour
la continuité de nos actions et des
enjeux majeurs pour l'université pas
avoir à faire à face
des semaines les années qui viennent non
vous l'avez dit vous remplacez le
professeur didier guillemot qui était en
poste depuis mars 2016 il il a remis sa
démission pour raison de santé vous
récupérez donc un mandat qui est en
cours et qui court jusqu'en 2020 est ce
qu'il est un poids particulier à lui
succéder
finalement à didier guillemot est ce
qu'il ya une difficulté particulière à
reprendre ce mandat en cours écoutez
j'ai j'ai mené la campagne avec didier
guillemot avec l'ensemble de l'équipe
donc en fait il ya eu des élections en
mars 2016 et la communauté nous a donné
confiance pour porter un projet donc
c'est avant tout un projet comporte
collectivement donc dans la continuité
est aussi en essayant d'améliorer les
actions futures sur des sur des projets
qui vont être structurant pour notre
établissement
vous avez justement défini plusieurs
grandes priorités pour votre mandat on
va en détail et quelques-unes notamment
alors une certitude c'est que l'avenir
de l'ue vs qu est tourné vers
l'université paris saclay ce
regroupement d'établissements de
l'enseignement supérieur créé fin 2014
et dont fait partie bien sûr lu vs qu il
a pour but de constituer un pôle de
formation et de recherche de premier
ordre mondial il faut approfondir le
projet actuel uv est ce qu a toute sa
place une place centrale aussi dans ce
projet lui est ce qu a complètement sa
place dans ce projet de paris-saclay
donc lui ai su a énormément d'atouts
cette université de recherche de très
haute qualité de formation en attestent
les classements internationaux alors
selon certains critères évidemment mais
qui nous place parmi les le top500 sur
classement de shanghai est au top 6 ans
sur les deux années consécutives et un
autre classement
th et higher education mais ce qui
forait euros blessés dans ces
classements là on est à la place de 20e
entre 20e établissements français au 12e
établissements français donc c'est à
dire que lui est ce qu est très bien
positionné a beaucoup d'atouts pour ce
projet qui est extrêmement porteur pour
l'avenir
vous souhaitez également alors impulser
la transformation numérique de
l'établissement il reste encore beaucoup
à faire sur ce sujet oui on a déjà mis
en place et on poursuit on a créé un
pôle numérique de transactions
numériques et d'innovation pédagogique
et donc on a déjà l'établissement a déjà
répondu à nombreux appels à projets et
notre volonté
avec les collectivités territoriales et
de faire de nos de nos campus les campus
numériques du futur ça c'est un point
très important mais qu'elles sont si on
en a encore quelques minutes avec vous
quelles sont les autres grandes
priorités
vous avez établi pour votre mandat alors
les autres grandes priorités c'est
évidemment penser à l'ensemble du
personnel de notre établissement nous
avons commencé déjà des actions de
revalorisation salariale et donc c'est
de poursuivre de permettre d'avoir des
postes pérennes sur qui de titulaire au
sein de notre université et tout ça est
réalisable d'ici 2020 où vous voyez les
choses à plus long terme je pense que
d'ici 2020 on avait déjà beaucoup à
faire il ya quelques jours aussi la
fondation de l'ue vs qui faisait l
actualité convention de mécénat signé
avec le crédit agricole d'ile-de-france
mécénat objectif soutenir le projet de
recherche sur la mieux profit à spinale
menée notamment par notre invité à
valérie robin avons donc envie d'en
parler je vous propose d'écouter les
raisons de ce soutien financier du
crédit agricole propos recueillis par à
nicolas kirillovitch une maladie qui est
quand même relativement courante et qui
est très handicapante et puis le fait
que cette jeune personne ne soit elle
même atteinte de cette maladie nous a
encore plus sensibilisées à la nécessité
de l'aider dans ses recherches assez
clairement
nous avons des potentiel intellectuel
qui ont quelquefois un peu de mal à
rester travailler en france et qui
s'exporte beaucoup donc leur permettent
de travailler ou d'exercer la fonction
surtout en début de carrière est
intéressant mais je pense elle valérie
robin qui est actuellement avec nous
également avec moi en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheuse au
laboratoire des maladies
neuromusculaires de l'université à
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
vous mener ce projet de recherche sur la
mieux profit spinale depuis cinq ans
c'est une pathologie dont vous êtes vous
même atteinte dans un souci de clarté
pour nos téléspectateurs
qu'est ce que c'est concrètement
l'amyotrophie spinale et qu'elles sont
finalement les les symptômes de cette
maladie
cette maladie génétique maladie rare
mais pas si rare puisqu'elle touche une
naissance sur 6000 mais surtout une
personne sur 40 dans la population est
porteuse de la maladie donc c'est quand
même beaucoup
donc c'est une maladie génétique qui va
causer la dégénérescence des
motoneurones de la moelle épinière et
qui va conduire à une atrophie
musculaire il ya plusieurs stades de la
maladie dont il ya des formes très
sévère ou les patients vont mourir très
jeune donc les enfants dans les
premières années de leur vie et des
formes moins sévère ou les adultes
continuent à marcher avec des
difficultés mais ne rompt pas de
problème plus que ça non vous menez jeu
les 10 des recherches depuis cinq ans
sur cette maladie l'amyotrophie spinale
est-ce que ça revêt aussi un caractère
particulier un sens particulier pour
vous deux heures faire des recherches
sur votre maladie bien sûr si je
travaille dessus c'est que forcément je
suis concerné donc c'est aussi une
passion du coup de travailler sur sa
propre maladie donc au quotidien c'est
forcément on a envie de mener les
recherches au bout oui ça joue le crédit
agricole ile de france mais ça vient
d'apporter 130000 euros pour votre
projet de recherche c'est une belle
enveloppe j'imagine en revanche qu'il
faut peut-être davantage dead pour ses
recherches vous développer des molécules
qui pourrait être une piste
thérapeutique très prometteuse
on va en parler dans un instant
d'ailleurs ouais c'est ses recherches
coûtent très cher la recherche coûte
très cher un générale effective donc oui
et c
c'est on va dire c'est ce qui nous
permet de continuer les recherches
actuellement puisque forcément avoir un
poste c'est aussi compliqué donc avoir
au moins des financements pour le
salaire et quelques parties du projet ça
nous permet à nous d'avoir de demander
des financements juste pour pour les
molécules etc
c'est une grande aide le professeur
alain vu ça faisait aussi partie de
votre profession de foi c'est primordial
mais pour une université d'être proactif
sur sur sa recherche
tout à fait madame robin est
l'illustration du dynamisme de la
recherche de notre université et je
voudrais remercier la fondation ups qi
la fondation du crédit agricole qui nous
aident la fondation ups que les
fondations qui nous aide aussi à
subventionner aco subventionner des ce
type d'actions de recherche et la
recherche
lulu dsq est une université de recherche
donc de recherche et d'enseignement mais
elle avec une recherche d'extrême
qualité et il s'en est tout à fait
l'illustration est important c'est aussi
de soutenir cette recherche ça c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait on a une
trentaine de laboratoires tous
extrêmement dynamique et porteur de
thématiques extrêmement intéressantes
pour le futur
on parlait de vos recherches vallières
les romains finalement calé tel est le
but de ces recherches qu'est ce que vous
espérez pas par ces roches et ultime
c'est de trouver une thérapie donc on
sait que ça prend beaucoup de temps dans
nos stades de développement préclinique
donc il ya encore beaucoup de travaux à
faire avant de pouvoir emmener cette
molécule chez l'homme mais mais nous
avons des résultats prometteurs
en tout cas qui qui nous laisse
envisager un bel avenir
une thérapie et l'idée c'est aussi
peut-être de pouvoir prévenir en amont
les enfin ce genre de maladie pour
éviter aux et de rentrer dans une
situation de handicap lourd c'est aussi
ça lui est sûre ça dépend des stades de
la maladie comme je disais ya plusieurs
formes de la maladie donc effectivement
différentes stratégies et vous avez bon
espoir oui sur sur vos recherches s'il
pensait que ça peut aboutir ça peut
aboutir pour les générations futures
donc ça fait cinq ans que vous
travaillez dessus vous travaillé
exclusivement sur sur ce genre de
recherche
oui mais en tout cas merci à vous
valérie robin rappel vous êtes la
chercheuse au laboratoire des
biothérapies et biothérapies des
maladies neuromusculaires donc à lui vs
q merci également aux professeurs alain
duault qui est le nouveau directeur le
nouveau président pardon de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines je
rappelle également que pour apporter
votre soutien à la fondation ups q vous
pouvez faire un don et ce dont se fait
au www.pontmercier.ca cu.fr le site à
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour nos
téléspectateurs
elle a dédié sa vie à la cause animale
le portrait de la semaine est consacrée
à marie laure caron depuis six ans cette
femme de 39 ans est la responsable du
refuge spa de plaisir un métier-passion
focus signé nicolas kirillovitch
marie-laure car on est ce que l'on
appelle une responsable dévoué 74 79
que ce soit la recherche d'une fiche et
la partie notre côté alors julien et ou
d'un collègue perdu le rythme de la
journée particulièrement intense en ces
jours de portes ouvertes à la spa
il faut être partout pour informer
rassurer et conseillers on est quand
même une très grande structure on a
quand même
à peu près de 150 chats au refuge et une
centaine de chiens c'est beaucoup de
paperasse et après on est quand même
beaucoup de salariés beaucoup de
bénévoles dont il ya tout ce côté là
chaque responsable le vit un peu
différemment après moi j'aime bien être
un petit peu
partout responsable du refuge de plaisir
depuis six ans la jeune femme consacre
toute sa vie aux animaux ici chats et
chiens sont recueillis par une quinzaine
de salariés pour espérer ensuite trouvé
une famille elle c'est une chatte que
nous avons récupéré de fourrière
justement qui qui a fait ces dix jours
de fourrière et malheureusement elle n'a
pas été récupéré par ses propriétaires
parce qu'elles n'étaient pas identifiées
donc quand on voit son comportement on
voit que c'est une à une une chatte qui
voilà qui al'habitude de l'humain dont
qui vivait obligatoirement dans un foyer
et c'est justement dans le foyer
familial que marie laure va développer
sa passion pour les animaux petite fille
la chambre qu'elle partage avec sa soeur
se transforme en refuge son parcours est
alors tout tracé
on travaille à l'espèce un rêve de
petite fille dont chacun ses rêves mais
le mien c'était vraiment de travailler à
la sp a et donc avec ma soeur ma soeur
jumelle qui est aussi responsable dans
notre refuge donc c'est très marrant on
a le même parcours
on avait déjà plein d'animaux quand on
était petit on était déjà très
responsable puisqu'on se lever une heure
plus tôt on se lave et très tôt le matin
pour s'occuper de nos animaux donc tout
le monde trouvait logique on finisse à
faire de la protection animale puisque
depuis tout petit ça nous suit depuis
son engagement est total pour la cause
animale de ses débuts en 2001 en tant
que bénévole jusqu'à ses fonctions de
responsable à plaisir ses qualités sont
appréciés et reconnus par l'ensemble de
ses collègues avec marie-laure faisait
partie de ces responsables de refuges
qui font bien à mon sens bien leur
travail dans le sens où ils ont une
éthique qui donc une vraie éthique de
protection animale a accepté
des animaux et pas toujours des animaux
facile parfois des vieux parfois les
animaux et du caractère des années en
plus rare des petits soucis de santé
ça demande du travail demande beaucoup
d'investissement mais là on est vraiment
sur un refuge il ya une super équipe de
salariés les bénévoles les aides il ya
vraiment une bonne équipe de salariés et
c c'est top pour les animaux c4 et la
dévotion que porte marie laure pour les
animaux ne s'arrête pas aux frontières
du refuge à la maison cinq chiens quatre
chats une tortue et des chevaux ont la
chance de profiter de sa passion
c'est un hymne aidiez à l'espace richaud
de versailles pour la première fois une
exposition met en lumière un artiste
contemporain
joseph dadoun l'invité de la 6e édition
de la nuit de la création le week-end
dernier
il est actuellement en résidence à
versailles grand parc qui est travail
sur le goudron le faire ou encore le
cuivre nicolas landry et mélanie poker
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une vie paradoxal joseph dadoun explore
la dualité le jour la nuit les couleurs
le noir un noir profond celui du goudron
travailler avec des outils d'ouvriers
le noir c'est c'est un point de vue de
la nuit la nuit on a su le cosmos
on a notre terre qui se retrouvent dans
le noir avec la lumière de la lune
et si vous remarquez bien dans ce noir
vous vous voyez la lumière s'accroche
aux éléments donc c'est un élément
poétique et c'est aussi un sentiment
c'est ce sentiment de simplicité de
grande humilité
un noir qui renvoie la terre un goudron
reflet de son passé celui d'une ville
ouvrière à la frontière avec gaza une
ville en conflit bombardé une terre
noire où poussent la vie
de là je ne pouvais que qu'avancer dans
un espoir et me projeter dans un espoir
et dans cet espoir ya ces fleurs
et je continue à être naïf et penser
qu'à travers mon art peut-être les
cultures pourront se rapprocher et que
les des deux côtés les gens feront la
paix une vision utopique assumée par
l'artiste avec sion joseph dadoun veut
sillonné la vie et le collectif le
week-end dernier c'était aussi la
deuxième édition du tournoi de poker à
manille flynn la formule est étonnante
puisque les participants se sont
retrouvés pour jouer durant 24 heures
non-stop au programme tactique jeux de
regards jetons et solidarité puisque
l'intégralité de la somme récoltée a été
reversée à l'association vivre au
village de magny les hameaux à nicolas
kirillovitch et les arrêts ch lunettes
de soleil sorti écouteurs dans les
oreilles les 80 participants au tournoi
manif line 2017 sont prêtes à enchaîner
24 heures deux parties de poker
l'endurance à 1 jouent un rôle important
parce que c'est une période où nous
vraiment sur ces heures de jeu quand tu
te fais prendre des jetons tout
simplement
il existe une variante qui a été fait
sur le château toute organisation là si
tu peux le faire à deux en fait joué en
duo
tu partages un peu les supplices 24
heures de jeu de difficultés mais
surtout de solidarité puisque en plus de
se retrouver entre amis les participants
jouent pour cette deuxième édition en
faveur d'une association pour
l'association caritative
on a pris donc vivre au village c'est
une petite association de magny les
hameaux qui s'occupent d'un petit
village en afrique et sont vraiment
super ils nous font des repeints
magnifique
association vivre au village solidarité
nord-sud est une association à but
humanitaire et dead au développement de
magny les hameaux
elle a pour vocation de soutenir des
projets de développement rural dans les
pays du tiers monde
le projet là concrets pour 2018 c'est
cris fication de d'une école à d'icônes
hop au cameroun qui nécessite un budget
d'environ 6000 euros c'est à une
électrification par panneaux solaires
donc complètement autonome sur la région
après 24 heures un temps sur les tables
de poker c'est thomas baileys alias coop
qui remporte le tournoi
l'association récolte quant à elle près
de 1400 euros on resta à magny les
hameaux pour conclure ce journal ou la
commune donne ses fleurs aux habitants
et des bégonias géraniums ou encore
pétunias qui ornaient les ronds-points
et jardinières elles ont été déterrés
dans le cadre du remplacement du parc du
parc floral de la ville plutôt que de
terminer à la benne ses fleurs pourront
ainsi connaître une deuxième vie
on écoute le maire de magny les hameaux
au micro de mélanie poker c'est une
notion de partage et puis au lieu de les
jeter directement elles continuent de
fleurir en fonction de la météo qui va y
avoir sur ces prochaines semaines
et puis c'est l'occasion que les
habitants ben repartent avec des fleurs
tout simplement l'occasion vraiment de
répondre à toutes les interrogations des
habitants que les habitants m va être un
visage aussi sûr
sur les personnes qui travaillent à
leurs côtés dans les services communaux
de distribution ont déjà eu lieu hier
une autre se déroule demain rendez-vous
au parvis qu'auront à sa main à magny
les hameaux de 13h30 à 15h30 est les
premiers arrivés seront les premiers
servis
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal avant
de vous quitter je vous rappelle deux
informations principales donc
aujourd'hui la journée de mobilisation
de la fonction publique c'est aussi une
mobilisation attrape des salariés de dhl
une vingtaine de personnes ont bloqué au
petit matin à l'accès du site du groupe
de transport et logistique
il a récemment perdu l'un de ses clients
et va délocaliser ses locaux aux
yvelinois à mitry mory en seine-et-marne
et les employés craignent des
suppressions de postes et une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
le mouvement est prolongée jusqu'à au
moins demain en attente d'une réponse de
la direction
et puis à 6000 euros damende dont 5000
avec sursis sentence du tribunal de
correctionnel de versailles contre l214
et deux militants de l'association de
défense animale ont été reconnus
coupables hier et de violation de
domicile en décembre 2016 il s'était
introduit clandestinement dans
l'abattoir qui a rang au 2 août dans
pour y poser des caméras et les images
filmées montraient la mise à mort
violente des ports les deux prévenus ont
été en revanche relaxé pour tentative
d'atteinte à la vie privée
ce journal vous pouvez le retrouver en
replay et les reportages également sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv et 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]